we are indeed uh alice congratulations
uh big victory for you and a difficult
one at that it felt like you were on the
defending end for the duration of the
game how did you feel and how do you
feel right now after this victory yeah
so i think um the opening like a kind of
neither of us knew exactly how to play
so i'm not sure how that went but uh
later she was kind of able to outplay me
and then she got
that queen side the a and b pawns on the
queen side
um but it wasn't so easy for it to
convert so i was able to trade off the
bishops and then
she missed that i could do rook takes b3
and after that
it was kind of hard for me to play for
her to play so right now you are feeling
that you're a bit on defensive but still
having some chances for equality and we
were surprised that after this move f5
and you got your king to f1 she did not
go for your h5 pawn with the king
did you expect her to do that were you
surprised that she didn't go for it yeah
i was expecting her to take on h5 and
then like later play b4 where i don't
think i really have um counter play and
then she's dressed up by
a pawn
but she decided to bring her keen in i
guess um
to
help with the queen side but
then she allowed me to do bishop takes
p3 and here she's forced to do a takes
p3 because i think if rectax b3 is in
rook a2
so after it takes b3 i kind of have a
blockade
um
that's what we thought as well yeah yeah
i thought that i was still had to defend
here did you see this uh moment this
idea of rook takes b3 from afar
were you hoping that she's going to
touch that rook when you gave the check
yeah so when i played rocket 5 check um
my hope was that she'd do recipe 5
the
rook on b4 if she had done that work
then i think i would have gone rook a6
um
and then
yeah then she can't move her keen and
the rooks are still kind of um awkwardly
placed so now it just feels like you're
getting close to potentially a perpetual
yeah
a repetition and
she played the movie rook to be how did
you assess your chances of winning at
this point did you feel like
you have good chances to uh to take the
full point home
yeah um so after i was able to play e4 i
wasn't sure whether it was winning or
not but i thought that i had really good
chances because
her clock was much lower and because i
can
press and play this position without any
risks of losing
absolutely and there was uh well a
smooth conversion after that uh
also accelerated by the fact that she
was so low on time at this point alice
congratulations a big victory for you
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few games thank you
wow our congratulations